now petrangelo with the point he'll feed it
towards the Ed and gorv gloves for the face
off including 12 in a row successfully killed they
made the jump from 17th last year up to number two
in front of tip by Stone and gorgia with a stop
Michael had the feed the stone Theodore lets it
rip and goria with a pass save been a quick play
initially as they vein Zone entry little play back
watch E go right away his Stone jumps to that
open area finds the open Ice good feed from Mel
in front a little tip as gurab with a good save on
Stone in deep trying to roll away from Josh Manson
nowel on the half wall curs up top wrist shot
safe the or with the rebound Stevenson couldn't
convert Manson blocks it Stone was camped out
of the top of the crease Stevenson the Theodore
15 seconds on the power play Maro down in front
Stone Rob by Goram the golden knights looking for
their first shorty of the Year Stone has a go off
his skate here down [Applause] low now mnav Stone
chars Mark Stone buries at point blank and the
golden I have their first shorthanded goal of the
season with it and here's Stone gets it back the
centering through little bank and watch McNab the
shot WIP Stone had to take an extra second to stop
that puck that long stick just pulls it back yoria
comes over watch as he pulls it back and then just
chips it over the stretch glove hand of gorg EV
andez with an eye on the wall on the tuskin
petrangelo gets it back and he'll snap it up
for Maro lead pass to W into the Zone shot score
what a shot upstairs for Jack eel and it's two
nothing golden knights tangelo going to Patient
marsho get separation there's the pass little
inside feet dieo with speed and in full stride
he releases that across his body watch this shot
by Jack eel takes the puck on the back him on his
right skate shoots a game that is a the McKinnon
charging through Center drops it off for linan now
Ma out high ranted and looking shot off the pipe
Martinez with a poke check Leon moves it off to
Johansson they'll swing it back to Taves around
it goes to McKinnon down low tip save made by
Hill a great little tip McKinnon little shot
off you have to stay sharp but look at the Stick
of Hills do a good job down low shot by Taves
block out of the box here's Bal Stone Banks it
to him Bal down the wing against T shot and a sa
gorab Stevenson will feed it stolen behind the
net avalanch had three shots on that power play
and a good look for Braden Bal fresh out of
the Penalty Box Stevenson to Stone to carry a
score will carry a his third of the season
it's three nothing Vegas at golds in three
straight games for carry pays off the Avalanche
just mismanaged the puck terrible turnover as
Stevenson gets it quick feed to Stone to carier
and he makes no mistake he goes blocker side on
gorv and the golden ice grab a three nothing lead
Maro to hit on feads it eel and spin away from the
chw skin Theodor keeps it in right on the line
Stone across eel shot score Jack eel second of
the period this one on the power play and the
golden knights have broken open two goal 52
seconds apart Mel gets it there's the pass look at
the reach keeps it in right to stone stone to AO
and that is pass gorv here here's the play at the
Blue Line great job to keep it in good cross seene
pass and a great finish from Michael and a little
delay at the Avalanche bench plck around the wall
and Theodore trying to push it down low rant it in
centering pass save made by Hill McKinnon had the
tip another shot on and he'll turn that away
well this is all an Kar had a chance earlier
in this ship to get it out he didn't and that
Top Line Avalanche maintained possession in a
couple of chances but Aiden Hill with a big save
[Applause] by a center dumps it [Applause] in the
last two losses for Colorado shut out losses on
the road were by identical four nothing scores
in Pittsburgh and buffalo stol defeated Stevenson
shot and gorg have got a piece of that need to get
it watch the effort here and gets on o Conor great
pressure Stone picks it up there's Stevenson that
hits the crossbar Stenson looking short side
but great pursuit of the puck keeps his feet
moving they got away with a little hold there a
little grab on OK Conor but there's the shot been
better over the last couple of games eel up ahead
hitting petrangelo petrangelo in shot save me
gior Colton snaps it around the boards vum playing
it back to the line but Stone tips it out Stone St
trying to get there against Tate Stone to the
net scor his second short handed goal tonight
Mark Stone and it's five nothing B just remarkable
what he's able to do little poke there and watch
he just about loses it and he will sees the Poke
chck from yab this is just the intelligence of
Mark Stone Here Comes po okay I'll just chip it
over what a finish what a play is Stone that his
second short-handed goal and the golden he grabbed
the five nothing lead taking him behind the
net out top to Theodore minute to go
on the power play Stone down low the
backand and gorgia also had one against San
Jose in the playoffs in 2019 oh this is a
great play by theer you see how high the
avalan are he sees the down low play and
stone kind of fakes the forehand tries to
come back and G just stays right with him
drewan pass intercepted by Doria up ahead
Carlson Rashad score a bad one on Goram the
most eot on the game this year is six and
William Carlson has his point streak up to
nine could extend his point streak and there's
D gorv sets him up and Carlson that's a little
shot right along the ice not sure there's
a partial screen no that's just one gorab
would like back as Carlson rips that watch
him pull it back into his body and he goes
five ho gor is maybe thinking short side up
high but Carlson up ice and William Carlson
off the door of and gor have got a piece of
[Applause] that Carlson and front scor what
a pass made it through to William Carlson and
he roofed it as the golden I have the extra
point work by dor F tries the first pass watch
he falls down maintains Puck possession going
to get out front with a backhand spin as
theano in front it goes right to Carlson
and watch the shot as Carlson right up over
the right arm of gorv his second of the game
so three guys have a pair of goals in this
one Carlson up to six deflected away to
Wood first shot from wood save made by Hill his
40th stop tonight wood with a drive that's kicked
out by Hill for save number 41 and a shut out
for Aiden Hill his first in the regular season